and another thing like I told you we
were out in the streets documenting some
stuff and doing some Street interviews a
lot of people on the on the the back the
blue side of things or on the Trump like
conservative side that were against the
black lives matter people they're all
talking about the George Soros guy yeah
who is George Soros he seems like some
big like like mystical figure a
worshipper of George Soros when I was a
kid really yeah because I started
following the stock market at night at
14 started trading when I was 16 I went
down the library and I ordered all of
the books written by the stock market
greats going back you know a century and
George Soros was big-time and he'd had
his books published about trade in the
stock market he almost bankrupted the
Bank of England when he saw his shot at
the pound and he made billions off it so
my muscle then after watching what that
movie wal stream was greed is good
all I heard about was being a
millionaire by the time I'm 30 mm-hmm
it's dog-eat-dog [ __ ] or be [ __ ] in
the business world right
I had no moral compass I just wanted to
make money so when you have no moral
compass and you just want to make money
you look up to people like George Soros
which is completely reversed you know as
you know my activism enough it now
helping school kids but yeah in my
twenties I was just testosterone fueled
financial maniac drug fueled I thought
it was cool that George Soros was making
billions and filed the highest income
ever in the history of the world for tax
purposes I thought that was cool I spire
to that back then yeah yeah so who is he
now why is everyone saying that he is
why does everyone say that he's funding
these people like black like black lives
matter and all okay okay so you've got
divide and conquer is the strategy used
by the elites
and the theory is that certain families
that was wealthy and powerful people in
the world including the Rothschilds
Rockefellers those kind of families who
control the politicians and that Soros
is a frontman for those families and he
does their bidding and theories are that
he promotes things that will increase
the divide-and-conquer factor in the
country okay so they think that he's
personally financing these these people
on the streets who are causing chaos
yeah well then it gets to the point were
that it's thrown around so much that
anyone who tries to do anything their
enemies just say well George Soros is
firing this is financing this guy just
trying undermine what they're doing so
what is the waters are so muddy with all
of this stuff it's hard to discern what
the truth is yeah it's really it's
really weird well on the subject of
black lives matter there was a guy I met
in prison called t-bone now yeah I was
on the yard and this t-bone black guy
almost six and a half foot just strides
across the yard the Sonoran Desert
looking like something out of a cone and
movie yeah just his biceps were bigger
than my head wasn't yeah cause of the
rules of racial division I never would
have approached him he was intimidating
the prisoners were finding out you know
that I was writing a blog getting pen
pals hooking people up with pen pals and
books so t-bone lingered in my doorway
one night I was just writing at my
little still table screw to the world
combination and the whole room went dark
has he completely blocked the sunlight
out holy [ __ ] just turn around and he
stood with his trousers on huh
everything they were on oh and I'm
thinking oh my god what does this guy
want but I got talking to him and he was
interested in English history and
military history in particular and we
hit it off now
t-bone I learned was using his skills as
a u.s. Marine to stop prison rape his
entire body was covered in scars not
tiny lot scratches horseshoe sized scars
from all the life and death prison
stories he had and also from the action
he saw as a u.s. Marine so he said it
was the finest thing anyone could do you
know he was very religious and he
believed that God had his back now if
you're intervening in someone getting
raped that's considered policing the
yard mm-hmm so that doesn't go down well
with a lot of the prisoners even even
though some people think rapes horrible
it's a good thing he's doing so you've
got a kind of division going against the
prison rules helping people being a hero
so he had to fight a lot of people and
oh boy could he fight so I showed up in
the library one time and the library was
being used as an outpost for [ __ ] so
I showed up in the library one time and
there's this big biker guy was getting
the [ __ ]
off this other skinny kid young person
and I walked in there said he's
everything all good and the kid told me
just to leave get out no wasn't my
business so I just left
now t-bone caught wind this and also the
guy was spreading rumors that t-bone was
a snitch now my cellmate was present
when what followed went down I had a
cellmate called Long Island he's the guy
who hooked me up with two Tony's okay so
Long Island was in the cell
belonging to the serial home invader
torturer guy right I tell you that one
in part one the guy Fred looking this up
yeah yes he would smash your head in
yeah so Long Island is in his cell and
then there's that guy we'll call that
guy bud the serial home invader tatra
okay there's another huge biker in there
called
Ken and he's massive and he's got his
cellmate in the cannonball it was the
guy who was forcing the young guy to
give him heads in the library you got
one two three white dudes in the cell
none of them as big as t-bone or as good
at fighting as t-bone but boy in
particular was quite psychopathic and
had these padlocking this up yeah so
t-bone walks in says the cannibal who
you callin a snitch cannonball said
something back offensive and t-bone was
just like Bam Bam Bam Bam on his face
knocked him out within seconds and his
head fell so hard against the toilet
water bounced out of the toilet and then
t-bar looks around the room at the other
guys and they all just froze because he
was about to take them out as well I
mean this guy was a [ __ ] killing
machine and yeah my cellmate was in
there Long Island Lee came back he told
me the story now the guy he hit tried to
hide it because that snitch and you know
if the guards see it's dry snitching
because if the guards need to see you
I'll beat up
yeah that's dry snitching so you gotta
hide it because of the yards gonna get
locked down they're gonna do a knuckle
check mm-hmm so the guy couldn't hide it
man he looked like he'd been hit by a
train I saw him when they took him off
the yard his face was like a blue blue
just all swollen up they sucked even off
the alphabet but they brought him back
on and he was lucky because they said
they were going to street
when they dropped it so I think they
supported what t-bone did on that
occasion
[Laughter]